someone else who likes to keep it real
Christina Aguilera yeah and last night
on Jimmy Kimmel Live while she wanted to
clear up one long-standing rumor the
feud between her and Britney Spears
being Britney we're definitely right you
know considered rivalry thanks Britney
if we had social media back then we
would have probably done like a song
together or something and just like
squash no social media back in the
Mickey Mouse Club days just media ready
to fuel a full-blown feud who has it
easier big sisters or little sisters big
sisters have way easier as their careers
took off in the early 2000s the press
quickly label Christina naughty Britney
wholesome and hypnotic even after her
racy video
[Music]
and I know three just who's got all the
attention for this Madonna kiss what
does it feel like to be kissed by
Madonna I cannot believe it's just like
freakin happened
yeah sorry Kristina but personal slams
did follow Aguilera called Britney quote
to unlost a little girl Spears reply a
lost girl I think it's probably the
other way around and when Britney got an
engagement ring in 2004 Christina said
quote it looks like she got it on QVC
and quote she's not trailer trash but
she sure acts that way but after Spears
became a mom in oh five they patched
things up even though people tried to
pit the then X Factor judge against the
boys coach you get along with her yeah
oh yeah she's a good friend and now
would you ever think about getting
everybody back together again
I would definitely show if I would go
definitely should do a song think you
would hey I'm down Oh wouldn't that be
fantastic
it is the greatest news ever Nancy
aren't you glad they get their friends
now yes their friends are moms I love
this so much
[Music]